everybody what's up welcome to Monday
melee yeah oh my god has everybody doing
welcome back we had a week off what did
you do last week ah that's great nobody
cares you screwed that up
Beth murasky and the chat hello twitch
hello YouTube
Jason I'm Ally creeper in the corner oh
my god so sad today I'm wearing my blood
shirt because we're playing a unique
horror adventure by Benjamin Rivers
called home now listen
ps4 playstation store had a flash sale
this is one of the games on sale it was
5 bucks
today we're streaming 60 frames per
second and there's no better way to do
that than an 8-bit game so I heard hello
everyone undisclosed username sunny
Sundays blues files variants want good
to see you
bear ski 180 oh yes as the Cannes Film
Festival last week it was super fun
we'll get into that later
shall we start this game I hear you can
beat this game in 90 minutes yeah so
we're gonna try we're gonna try to beat
this game in 90 minutes let's do it our
happy home a single City how about this
don't tell me how to live Benjamin
rivers yeah turn up the sound turn off
the lights we're not gonna do that
because then you wouldn't be able to see
us what's up blob 350 two's internet
connection sucks hombre good to see you
what's up I'm good mr. Joe Josh howdy is
that how you say that my god somebody
doesn't hear anything perfect all I
remember to that point was finding
myself alone oh so this game is exactly
my life fair enough now guys we've got a
new thing in the office I don't know if
anyone wants to know a little bit behind
the scenes at the Conan show they're
sailing by my speed a flashlight we have
this new stuff called Lacroix it's
Lacroix there's all different kinds of
flavors we're obsessed with drinking
seltzer water here so that's our name
thing I'll be drinking a lot of it you
want some of this okay what flavor do
you want this is cran-raspberry I'll
take anything
this is Cameron
Barry ok you want Barry yeah I just
don't like the coconut one okay yeah
there's coconut that tastes kind of like
suntan lotion so Red Sox captain there
you go now you're famous this game I bet
loves the Red Sox now you've ruined the
stream goddamn Red Sox
all right this game is we find ourselves
alone in a house we look just like Conan
O'Brien by the way I know I thought this
was like purposeful or like we did this
this is hilarious yet so far not scary
I'm just gonna put that out there I
don't know if a an 8-bit game can make
me scary lacroix we so fancy product
placement of video games these days
that's right if we can get free look and
also send me more free blood shirts
because I had to pay for this one I had
to paper oh by the way which suck that
house where was I
what is this this is jelly let's look at
it there is a body lying on the floor
who was it it was my mother oh god
there's a cat who what's this this is a
giant dildo what is this here it looks
like a giant dildo come on is that just
me guys dildo yes no let's hear it chat
yes no deal though I want a hashtag it's
not it's exude it's not too early for
dildo hashtag yes dildo hashtag no do
though I want I want people to vote
here's a nice fern okay we can go in
there let's look at let's explore this
room a little bit more what's up bear
ski those jump scares Moody waffle says
ooh there's something dripping from the
ceiling not making any noise Benjamin
rivers you forgot to add the noise for
this trip should we go down the basement
I think we're gonna ignore the basement
for now and go through this door yup yup
yup see everyone agrees with me everyone
is agreeing yes dildo yes deal though
yeah Wow
and by the way YouTube shat really into
the dildo so god bless you this they
missed a wallpaper spot there there's
some books I like to read the desk out
of computer and some papers on it and a
single drawer I didn't want a snoop but
yeah did I open the drawer and by the
way
saying this in the past tense so are we
dead do we open the door yes we did
seeds pens and a blurry photo uh-oh
looks like a store of some kind why does
this look so familiar this is just
memento the game ooh what's this smell
fresh oh there's blood of my shoes and
pants oh no I done murdered somebody
maybe I just maybe I was just making my
famous Aryan blood spaghetti sauce the
blood that's the secret ingredient don't
please don't blurt it out there we go
Pooh
I'm eating found the porn stash ooh
we'll use blood in your porn stash
that's terrible I had to get out of
there you had to get out of there by
walking at a medium pace exactly you
enter Conan talk down to me guys then if
you want to hear me getting made fun of
tune into clueless gamer tonight with
the game of thrones folks Peter Dinklage
and Lena Headey and Conan O'Brien and
we're all playing overwatch and it's
really fun and I get made fun of pretty
hard like normal there you go it'll bill
the internet by 8:00 East Coast time I
noticed that I limped as I moved down
the stairs how did I hurt my leg I
wondered this is by the way this keeps
you to be called the morning after the
blaze story yes this is exactly me I
wake up after night drinking I'm covered
in blood there's bodies everywhere but
bodies I mean like half-eaten tacos and
burritos
I could really recall was coming home
right seeing Rachel ooh I was upset she
looked afraid I shook my head and tried
to clear it I knew I should head
downstairs try to find a way out there's
those just windows you can't recall out
of a window there's a clock I hold the
door what does that mean by the way I
see Game of Thrones I haven't seen it no
yeah it's gonna be fun moody waffles
it's gonna be great here we go through
the characters and make fun of a bunch
local shelf is full of books okay seems
like that's a weird thing to say the
owner really knew the area of this house
Wow and the basement just keep going
down
whoo what's this is the cat humping
something or is it like mousetrap
oh yeah it's red look at this filth oh
and over here that's grreat
let's free it hold the door
here we go yeah we're freeing the mouse
by mouse but by the way there's a cat on
the loose so you're [ __ ] I think hold
the door wha more of these a collection
of rusty tools to bury a body with blood
why were they in a shed like I get it
like we're insinuating that I've killed
someone and buried them right okay I
mean some oh is this me Rachel oh we
pushed the switch for sure it depressed
smoothly into the wall I'm smoothly
depressed also most nights heard a
far-away click somewhere I hope so
humping cat this game Oliver Sylvan is
home by Benjamin Rivers and so far we
can't figure out what these things are
but they look like dildos I'm sorry
Aaron trust me watch the episode then it
will hit okay fair enough murder murder
very scary
I think the mouse is gonna prove to be
quite the notes about some kind of water
tower did he mean the one by the old
train you aren't sure how am I supposed
to know I'm new to this place now
there's a smells turning my stomach wait
I don't see what that was
how long have its been here rotting the
main man upstairs didn't look like he'd
been dead a long time huh what is this
over here a black-and-white photo looked
like the man upstairs and his wife I
guess there's no reason for me to keep
this did I take it I'm a hoarder so I
take things I mean we don't have an
inventory so we might as well take it
yeah
they go to put six r3g why yes my shirt
just says blood in giant letters and
there's a lot of O's because when I
think when I see this shirt I just think
like
you know like yeah like wha
all right we took the photo why wouldn't
I take it there's no we don't know how
many things we can hold we might as well
wait down exactly as a coincidental that
the tio w4t Jackie says as it quits Ella
the character looks like Conan yes it is
I can't figure out I think it's like a
mascot or maybe that's hey it might be
like a lot of taco meat that's what I
call it guys when they wear like a
v-neck and then there's hair at the
bottom yeah we call it taco meat that's
that's in your brain now internet taco
meat
my friend Tony's Eric came up with that
taking portraits equal bad luck we'll
see about that
someone said ever since the Wien
Cunningham thing where he told Conan to
go [ __ ] himself you laughs when the
greatest dude lien cunning at Liam come
hands off some yeah what happened was
last year at comic-con and we're going
back to comic-con this year I should
comic on Conan interviewed the whole
cast of Game of Thrones which you watch
in 360 on our site and he forgot to ask
me and liam Cunningham a question so
Liam was nice enough to come back the
next day and tell Conan to view a [ __ ]
yeah I look like hell my clothes were
dirty and torn there was mud caked all
over my shoes and don't forget all the
blood dude remember were covered in
blood blood front door is blocked by a
pile of furniture I knew I had to find
another way out why I can't lift
furniture come on bro Benjamin rivers
what are you doing doesn't even take a
day off after can damn straight dr. Ben
when we go we go hard let's open this
door mmm
bathroom is spotless everything had to
be white to a sheen I wonder if there's
the man's wife who did the cleaning or
him or me cuz I probably killed somebody
yeah if this game ends up where I killed
somebody I'm gonna be very disappointed
don't give me all these clues and then
follow through on them
yeah we need a misdirect we've seen
enough stories in our lives where we
know where this is going
there's summat what's in the tub all
right so we developed some photos oh
this is so scary
wait this game isn't scary at all all
right I thought I saw it look like tree
tops or is it broccoli at a high
magnification nailed it
thank you hashtag broccoli jokes clean
the rest of the bathroom was who maybe
it was placed there on purpose okay
great all right dude does look like
Conan I agree
oh you think my character is the
murdered one said Eureka oh that's an
interesting twist that could be fun ah
maybe it's like that Nicole Kidman movie
which one is it where they're all ghosts
turns out sorry spoiler Li others Laura
Jackson yes I wasn't can up until
Saturday night it was amazing I saw some
great you know me also you got some
photos from can you know some great can
photos okay you know you guys won't you
go you want to see a canned photo real
quick all right the door was taped up
and seemed to be stuck by the smell I
guess it led to the kitchen because it
smelled like Hamburger Helper which is
delicious and my favorite food I know
I'm so hungry here's a photo so I saw a
bunch of great celebrities in can a
couple of celebrities I saw where where
that's that's nope nope that's not gonna
work that's not gonna work
here's a great this is an exclusive
Monday melee celebrity photo of let's
see here let's see here's you got your
thank you for hosting what about this
yeah thank you for us yes
you got your you got your Kristen
Stewart there Kristen Stewart there you
go run it towards the camera
why do you run it towards me there's a
Kristen Stewart and a nice pretty dress
there you got your Kristen Stewart there
signing some autographs there she looked
really pretty great she was there for a
movie called personal shopper where
she's a person trying to find her dead
brother or something I don't know
there's her with her dress it's very
very glittery pretty dress you got your
you know yet your you got your Donald
Sutherland I don't know if you guys are
famill you guys for Chloe's 70s there's
Chloe Sevigny in a hat they're turning a
hat right there it's pretty great
uh yeah sounds great I saw a lot again
Salieri's this one good time can I
highly recommend it if you have the
chance to go very fun all right
are you ever gonna put a fan since
Oliver Sylvan yes absolutely
we will you know what maybe we'll play
the fans next week should we go down I
feel like something unlocked and we
should go back upstairs is that crazy
picture would that click that's what I'm
saying and unlock something but do we
want to go maybe back up you want to
backtrack or do we want to go down I
don't know all right let's keep going
down yeah the box looks heavy but the
remarks of Florida obviously been moved
before maybe I'd found a way out
I must have moved it right no no no I
left a little bit couldn't think of
another option so I guess I gotta move
it should I want to check upstairs to
see if anything's been unlocked my gut
says oh wait a second wait do we is this
the bathroom oh no this is the kitchen
ooh spooky sheets of paper all over the
kitchen table look like a series of
names were written out there to smudge
to read can only make out a few of the
notes keycard Locker last one I promised
it makes much sense at the time it's
like that scene in lost remember where
he goes in the cave and he sees all the
numbers and the writers didn't know what
they were doing so it didn't really make
any sense yeah a lot of people forgot
that sorry I love lost but lost you
thought you buckle the ending there guys
that's right Kate Conan please says
Kelly Kelly you'd oh there's someone I'm
oh let's see I like how you guys are
down to earth and not suits thanks
soccer man appreciate that and I like
soccer I like the game that you've named
your thing after Chloe oh Savini Savini
got a close Evita I think I think 70 I
ran into her three times by the way at
the airport which is hilarious yeah no
didn't talk to her now then I ran into
her the American pavilion then I ran
into her it again just walking by but
yeah also Nick Kroll was there so that's
got your Nick Kroll got your curtain
dunces
I don't know what what's the plural of
Dunst Kirsten Dunst not done see done
seasons done that seems weird to Sam
Dunst Z or did it eat the man upstairs
yeah Clues gamer tonight oblivious miss
that's right you guys we're going all
the way back up to the beginning where
it all started with our first dildo Oh
the man's face what look
like the man in the photo I'd found wait
you know what baby this is me hey wait a
second his face oh wait he's kind of
like that does this kind of look like me
wanna taco meat a lot of taco meat there
yeah that might be me guys I found my
own dead body what a twist
all right well nothing's up there um
yeah you guys how is everyone else in
the chat whats going on guys tell me
something exciting wait we didn't go
this way did we
ooh we did go this way cuz it's the
computer room in the blood room get over
it why is the blood orange nobody knows
it could be the TV all right we're all
right oh here's gonna watch the gaint
watch clueless gamer tomorrow guys
overwatch who's been playing overwatch
that's a fun game my favorite is the
monkey guy Winston it's a moon monkey
this is what I do in games I shouldn't
go back and I do and then I get lost
this is crazy over watched tonight oh I
Biggs I gotta king 222 K 14 any good day
I think we're just gonna go I think we
got to move the box it just want it's
hurting us into movie this yeah yeah
yeah okay fine yeah I moved it also you
know what he could be dead because he's
talking in the past tense yeah she's
like is this what I did hmm maybe this
is we were snooping around someone
else's house and we got jacked you know
somebody popped a cap in our ass like
blah blah blah like blah like put the
Rihanna I'm pretty sure that yeah yeah
exactly
I felt like Rihanna was here yeah yeah I
climbed down the ladder there's nothing
else to do there's nowhere else to go
scientist he's a scientist Anna monkey
thank you he is a primate of some
but he was raised on the moons any
super-smart let's see I looked again at
the photo I found in the house a couple
of distant like they didn't want to be
in the same picture where the wife was
that's pretty it's a big assumption I
think I looked at the photo she looked
like a real [ __ ] what the [ __ ] she's a
normal person my leg was in a terrible
shape I had to get out there we go
oh we're outside hey how cool well this
is fun oh no we're not outside sorry I
want a dank basement oops obviously
useful action it's my killing room hey
it's like true detective yeah all the
notes in the wall this old map for the
town industrial here near the river
various houses in the water there we go
water tower use paper clips in the local
paper they're all about murders in the
town am i a murder yeah oh this could be
fun if I'm a murderer boys wanted to be
a murderer you know yeah alright there
were photos photos of our house what the
hell was that about maybe I should have
looked around more tried to find some
kind of information no a worktable
covered in papers dirt and a handgun I
hated guns yeah I took it
are you of course I took it yeah it's
weight was reassuring best part about a
gun you can also kill someone with it
just by hitting them yeah it's like
basically a rock that shoots bullets
that's how I think of guns you know I'm
not good at firearms oh where you going
down again I'm going down again
stealing putrid you know putrid is a
word I don't get to use that off and I
would like to use it yeah like hmm my
personality is a little putrid right now
is I think that's a good use of that
word do you think so it's kind of stinky
I believe what I saw what was this place
guys what was it why oh there's another
desk the desk look oh that was cake good
crime you know there's not a lot of
horror going on in this horror game
there's a lot of reading maybe you know
when they were naming the game maybe it
was like home a reading adventure game
by Benjamin Rivers you know instead of
like a horror so much cares
yes something on it right exactly it's
really
yeah I can't even read I've list XE air
or dyslexia mmm did you buy a putrid
shirt oh that's a great idea
exactly I just me I'm with putrid and
they're just pointing up I was a stack
of old faded paper covered it will look
like names more names man uh uh few
letters how are we supposed to be like
writing this down I I will say this is
probably the victims of people were you
wheel of fortune yeah ooh the hangman
none of it made any sense to me
well thanks for telling me here is a
honey alright what is this a beehive
down here oh boy we're going down again
Oh hooks to put bodies on yeah hit it
and work from heavy use yeah that's
right get this butcher on crudely made
shelves so you can just set from Ikea
they look like they're holding cans of
some kind of corrosive I get it like
just we're killing people on their
bodies or now we're mounting them we get
we understand we've seen a movie pew
yeah Eureka goes putrid exactly meat
hooks always a good sign hope my hands
are not too sweaty since action Jack 93
they are fairly sweaty but morally it's
from all the reading yeah still see the
warnings the slight fumes it's automatic
from the cans made me dizzy ooh wait a
second can we stay yo bro you get high
on putrid fits Oh a cage something wet
ooh what is that what do you think soup
yeah like a chowder yeah like some kind
of like a-- do you like a New England
chowder okay why did I even why did I
got Captain New England over here
what else is in anything a place is
getting worse all the time I knew I had
to keep moving no when you say a place
is getting worse all the time you go
back you idiot homemade racks Len
together poorly cut wood and rope caked
with old blood so he didn't actually use
that did they smell that old room was
like Blair's body
I wasn't getting any closer to finding
anything useful yeah we know dude our
life is meaningless and everything is
murder
so far this case oh my god a brooch
today we're playing at home a horror
game by Benjamin Rivers it's a very well
done game I will say I like the graphics
I like this look I think we're just
frustrated cuz we're confused but this
game probably wants to confuse it wants
to confuse you we're a little confused
there's not a lot of horror happening
but it is a 90-minute game they've said
so we're only the first third and all
horror movies the beginning is the most
boring oh yeah because they're setting
stuff up and then they do a turn you
know like if you see it follows one of
my favorite recent movies the beginning
is kind of a little boring and then it
gets crazy alright okay some kind of old
boxes they look like there are years old
wait a minute these boxes had old
clothes in them oh oh
vintage maybe idea we take the clothes
go upstairs the computer you put them on
eBay make a little cash clean this place
up a bit by some air fresheners get rid
of that putrid smell clothes I remember
throwing out after Rachel I moved to
town this is his house we're a killer we
all know it the point of lifting the
light I'm not sure these pixels are
horrifying sis John we on 13 right I'm
just looking around you know see if
there's anything around here we've got a
lot of good batteries Oh
oh it's on now y'all see we're just
about at the point where all right I
think those are bats this turns out
we're in the bat cave
we're actually Robin had to be careful
oh can I jump do you jump down but I
think we have to keep going down right
where it goes
is there another I think he's faking it
that looks like a pretty pronounced lip
yeah do we just jump down or can we jump
across there's nothing else I can only
do these two things by the way this is
the only do you want to body
Oh sugar says the later acts were
terrible you're insane what about the
part where they're in the cabin and he
breaks through the door is awesome
it follows is amazing I won't hear any
any crap about that walk over okay oh
yeah you're right thanks appreciate that
this is it yeah guys were playing on
charted for today graphics just kidding
we played on charter for last week and
it was amazing by the way I've started
playing uncharted this series of my own
personal life because it's fun because I
want to get all the because I hear
uncharted 4 there's a lot of cool Easter
eggs are you guys like you got charted
for who's ever played it cuz I hear it's
unbelievable
only if I beatbox there's a rope hanging
there I wasn't sure how sturdy it was
did I take it yeah I take everything
there we go see if there's a weight
limit why wouldn't you just take
everything there we go we got the rope
oh it's a skeleton but I can't see it
somehow maybe that's my skillet to me
that's me it was a mirror
dad dad have you had Manhattan clam
chowder yes it's the red one right yeah
Wow you said that was such disdain it's
the red one right I think it's like it
has tomato in it I think so happy faint
hum and the smell from before start to
get worse oh man bodies oh you got more
boxes we got some lights you know
candles down here oh we got another old
newspapers we pasted together that's a
weird thing to say especially basil
smeared I keep out danger due to cave-in
we're going in baby descent 3 let's do
it who's Hodor
hmm here we go the Oyster Bar Grand
Central
that place is great yeah waste your bark
still feel a faint impression of the
rope I'd slid down as I press against a
heavy metal door this could be a sexual
phrase by the way yep still feel a faint
impression of the rope I had slid down
as I pressed against the heavy metal
door its warmth warm my bodice in the
right you like Jane Austen [ __ ] right do
not get this feel very much like Jane
I'd mean correct me I'm wrong it's
probably for the best that hadn't jumped
the ache in my leg was bad enough as it
was okay good job I could have though I
would have run straight out of those
awful tunnels who keeps such a place I
don't know me yeah
when I had a memory of being a killer at
least I thought I'd found the old
handgun it seemed to work
I smell I've been used already wait a
second I'm getting I'm getting the idea
here that we're actually gonna leave and
go out into the world because we're
talking about everything we've done in
the house huh okay but I kept the gun in
my pocket it seemed too familiar wait
they're familiar cuz I've used it to
kill some people blood oh yeah here we
go oh now it's on oh oh do we go up or
did we go over like water I looked over
nobody there was a man urinating we
locked eyes and began undressing I just
want this to become like a sexual
adventure all right here we go
exit found the exit a kitchen knife
covered in duct drying blood shockingly
like everything else around here it's
covered in blood do you want to touch it
yeah we took the knife come on what are
we doing we're already covered in blood
why would we not yeah you did we do
we're gonna be killing people soon
it's a pile of rocks near the ladder all
right I didn't see the rocks near the
ladder do I need to go back can I tell
you a story about Cup oh here we go
there's dirt on the ground it looked wet
and there was grass smeared with in it
it was covered in blood
right oh look at this
exposed ventilation chef maybe someone
crawled through there but it was so high
up that it must have been a sore landing
that's how I hurt my leg let's climb up
and see what's up here
Jiki maybe - Coco must his blue blues
whole budget on this game you're like
because we're taking all the weapons
we're making ourselves the killer but if
we had chosen not to take them maybe is
that true I don't know what that Oh
so that's a filthy garbage bags or rips
and tears in most of the bags very much
like my house again I really need to
take out the trash what look like an old
videotape was sticking out yes we're
taking everything yeah well we'll find a
VCR I'm sure let's go back down you
wanna see Conan bully me jhm fcz then
turn on the TV tonight and watch
clueless gamer with Peter Dinklage and
Lena Headey he D an overwatch it's gonna
be fantastic
I hope you guys like it I get made fun
of very hard which is what everybody
wants to see really oh boy so many doors
which door my going in Beth one two or
three - hope we find something covered
in blood
kind of regulator blood regulator it's
not working yeah we turn it turn it baby
we turned it we're back now 1 or 3 oh
wait there's numbers here wait it says 1
and that says two let's go in this one
yeah I actually missed numbered the
doors then - here we go yeah we turned
it anyway we turn all the valves that's
the rule three four let's go this way
yep turn them all on yeah yep yeah yeah
turn them all on you know this is gonna
get us the hot water in the shower it's
gonna help us wash off all this blood
exactly alright well we did it in the
right order we did the valves everybody
if you're just joining us for playing
half-life 3 today we got a preview copy
this is it long waited half-life 3 it's
uh you know I haven't played the first
two half-lives so I assume it's this and
I don't know what the story is exactly
but it's pretty fun so far we're
fighting the combine oh my gosh
bring Conan and he's actually funny
you're right Conan is actually funny but
does he have a shirt this is blah
hashtag blood oh we turn the valves to
flood the town someone said oh whoops
I don't know saying there's a rusty
ladder stuck into the water which is not
discussing I knew I couldn't climb down
then maybe I could find a way to drain
the putrid water wait dude i drained the
putrid water didn't I with the valves
did I not turn the things right blares
maybe we did the wrong thing by doing
the thing it's locked god damn it I got
to go back and turn these valves oh wait
hey look like I turned off the water
flow in this valve oh good yeah but
maybe I just missed one of the valves I
didn't hit the right thing like an idiot
shocker me do the wrong thing I know
guys what am I thinking or their blood
valves oh yeah here we go there we go we
turned it we just didn't do the other
one there boy yeah it turns out all the
blood blood valves yes here we go Oh see
we already did this one all right good
job good job me all right so far a few
scares oh boy are these two dating is
this a precursor to Netflix and chill
right I keep asking bet to marry me but
she keeps saying no she's holding out
for somebody from Boston he's cuts roots
exactly she won't settle for a Midwest
boy like myself she's got high standards
and you know what you need to have high
standards in life and putrid waters
still there putrid goddamnit yes cgz 22
clues gamer tonight on Conan hey you are
[ __ ] kidding me with this valve [ __ ]
Mike going back and doing these valves
again dude all right this one's off oh
wait oh we got to do the regulator thing
wait wait wait there's a regulator
remember the regulator Oh
okay great doesn't help me at all
fantastic hashtag friendzone there and
welcome to the group yeah thank you here
up here yes what's up to 289 good to see
you Dinklage tonight son of a [ __ ] I
turn this valve Oh is this is this a
knock on valve the software company
maybe this is a not gonna valve a
summary yes turn it dick
this is like a mind game okay that's off
that's off they're all off there another
place to go there's no other place to go
man they're all off all right this one's
back on again oh this is a whorehouse
this is a frickin Torah gate
yeah shut it off u-turn yes I hit the
button here yeah the puzzles [ __ ] be
here the rest of this yeah this is
basically gonna be it yeah Val don't
make me turn okay that one's off through
the dust the whole thing I turned all
the goddamn valves let's go back it's a
bit there's nothing to look at maybe Joe
change the order of the bells
yeah I'll change your order of the
valves [ __ ] all right fine ah
all right this picture eyes to the valve
all right fair enough okay here we go
okay let's look at some oh wait
hopefully you solve this puzzle before
the street ah who said that who said
that waffle tarts awesome waffle tar
everybody follow waffle tarts that's the
greatest comment of the stream so far
great is common in the stream the new
valve game with too hard
yeah well played all right here's my
question though there's nothing else for
me to do here guys we've reached a
simple puzzle which is going to kill us
for the rest anything to solve this
puzzle what did he wear this dream man
greatest memory of Sabri yeah Sombra was
on the summary was never playing
superhot yeah and Sombra was on that
thing that's right sovereign yes we shut
it I don't get this man we have those
pictures that oh you know what wait a
second this one oh yeah look at the
things here wait this one needs to be
the other way so you look for is like
this right if you see the dot the light
color dot oh oh oh oh so this one I need
to say no to no I left the valve alone
but how do I turn it back the other way
so that says no wait this one oh oh I
see okay wait so I guess we need to go
back to the yellow Square position to
the dot position on the wall picture
yeah but I can't turn it more
okay got it got it alright alright thank
you who said that in the chat thank you
yeah Yuriko well done and we do it again
and we do it again
oh I don't hear any noise that's cool
got it nailed it this is boring that's
right since chica well thank you for
watching our boring stream I appreciate
it this is all day yeah that's what we
do man weirdly this is also what we do
just in life yeah we turn well oh wait I
go back to the regulator and see what's
up oh we don't care about this we did
this already
what Conan's not good at turning valves
what can I say
flem Conan I mean all right back to the
putrid water everybody I love it when I
can use that the word putrid ah down the
ladder we go Cody Cody Hardin this is a
game called home by Benjamin rivers it's
a horror game which is why I'm wearing
sure this is blood I think the water
drained out of that grate in the wall
mmm there's a small amount Keela
floating in the shallow pool of red so
why don't I take it of course we take
everything probably the small kiba's so
odd-shaped had no idea what it might
open hmm
well there is a locked door upstairs you
should probably go up to let's look at
this we've definitely seen better days
hell does that facility I don't know man
why you asking me these questions should
we go up and try that locked door yeah
let's do it we go back up
bug in here huh that's a weird bug look
now this is a horror game I hate bugs
little bugs are the worst I'd rather
have a bit I'd rather fight a big bug
than a tiny bug tiny bugs like like just
go right my nose you know I'd rather
fight em yeah that's true
big bugs at least it's like you can grab
it just [ __ ] smash it bro key can't
use the key now all right fair enough by
Conan overwatch tonight tonight Condor
brain brains it opens brains is Eureka
brain what's in the box small box urn I
agree Excalibur 2x smell bugs are the
worst way worse than my singing I think
we can all agree that I have a beautiful
voice uh faint light within it's like
the hatch this is basically lost you
guys I walked past a normal door and I
go right into this door Power Move smell
a hint of fresh air here was that close
to the exit as anxious to leave but
worried that I missed something so the
videotape I carry to go back you know
more blood another body
whoa sewer worker by the wounds all over
his face and body I feel like been
stabbed repeatedly with my knife oh man
I get to oh I'm feeling a little stabby
anyway yes we took the keyring come on
you dick well I was almost worried he
was going to grab me grab me come at me
bro come at me all right fine you know
what I don't feel sick from seeing a
dead person I feel a little depressed
ooh what's this
Oh a security camera okay so here's what
happened we have the VHS tape of me
killing that guy right stabbing and
repeatedly in the face like this yeah
you know probably was yeah like a round
like this and then in the head yeah
almost a B so when the head is not a
great idea cuz their skull is there yes
don't stab in the head guys yeah it's
not kind of fleshy er please yeah bless
your place I like you know like around
like yeah but and so I think the VHS
tape is me killing that guy and I tried
to throw it away that's my prediction
predictions what do we think guys
predictions what's gonna happen here
this game feels like a job yeah this
game is a job who tell you another
ventilations laughs other end of that
ventilation chef whoever used it could
have gotten past that flooded room with
this yeah well good thing I didn't do
that instead I'd spent 30 minutes
looking at valve norovirus what's the
cut of my leg I really need that gunner
that knife before the end well yeah I
should right wait should I go back down
should I go back down here I'm feeling
like maybe I should go back down and get
rid of that stuff but I can't get ready
it doesn't let us know like yeah there's
no it doesn't let me undo stuff so we're
kind of screwed should I go check those
rooms again if they're locked wait were
there any locked rooms in the house oh
there were that there's that Warren's
door all right should we go back and
check that room all the way back
should we go back all right guys you're
watching this also we want to make you
part of the stream should we go back and
try the key on that very first lock door
it's a ways back got a keyring you can
never go back
escaped to Mexico you have the key keep
moving forward yes I should seriously
close all right you people to keep the
sewer
it's boarding downstairs keep going
leave it so it's too late to go back
keep moving I'm horny okay great got a
simple modern tennis we know you're
horny man we get it a guy got it yes
you're keyrings fall back go
back you made a choice Omar cash says go
back Lois doesn't go back before the
stream all right should we go back
people are saying go back all right
we're gonna go back we're going back
oh no we're screwed we can't go back all
right
oh now we're a killer
what is this scary noises there's a bug
in here good stupid bug it's a horror
show all right here we go
oh I saw some eyes in the darkness oh
this way I'm gonna walk past this and
wait should we go in here wait there's
like dogs and stuff in here oh no oh no
there's like dogs and stuff all right
things are getting a little freaky I'm
into this you know oh thank you okay
things are getting a little freaky the
old train station was quite a train
station man bro
so is that increasing wind buffeting the
decrepit structure I will say I like the
way that this is written yeah decrepit
and putrid are great words all right
you're in a train station man there's so
much what's up with the dripping going
on man goo everywhere mmm
you know home is a great there's a
restaurant called home actually two that
I really like and this is not at all
like that all right
ancient ticket booth was falling apart
and covered in dust and grime what does
go why is everything covered in dust and
grime yeah why this is why you need
higher taxes guys I hate to get
political here yeah give me a minute
infrastructure mmm you can't abandon
infrastructure you can't or else you get
games like this I bet you murdered the
entire town if I were the entire town
like yeah
game on by the way paper newer looking
sheets covered in scribbles on legible
notes and come to think of it the man in
the house that kept still no scribbles
in the bookshelf and he had notes on the
water tower outside to guess he could
have been coming here then why what was
using the old station for to hide the
bodies ooh oh man
if only if only
well the overwatch Ashley says you the
overwatch gameplay be uploaded on
YouTube that's the question yes it will
be it will be on youtube I have answered
your question guys I will say it's
trained as forms of Transportation go
trains have to be up there is my
favorite yeah they're smooth they're fun
you chill they're safe here's a big map
no map occasion glass I'm training
routes getting that old station seem
familiar of course it's where I used to
move all the bodies locations marked aha
that's how he kills he goes around on
the train hiding his bodies man indeed
you ever seen Money Train what are you
Harrelson and what's-his-face Wesley
Snipes great movie it's actually a
terrible movie Oh what's this what
though
wait wait a second wait a second wait a
second wait a second I see a whole train
ripped apart Smasher a fence in a
decrepit town with putrid smells and I'm
noticing of a dirty cloth that's what I
notice it's a ripped up train what are
you talking about I'm focusing on it I
would be like holy [ __ ] look at this
train well you see the wounds in the
Train oh my god are you kidding me
it looks synthetic like so kind of outer
world why am I talking about this tiny
thing it's a whole train that's been
ripped apart this guy's crazy okay oh
I'm so angry
how angry I just get oh god I feel
light-headed I need some more Lacroix
still the most delicious seltzer water
out there okay inside the Train shell I
can see a few feet impacts like wounds
fine then bullet marks somebody's shot
there with my gun the ground was
well-worn so I couldn't really make
anything out except for my own
footprints and a note that said you've
killed them all sign to me I realized I
was touching the gun I found as I
thought Oh shouldn't have taken that gun
I wonder if I I will say I wonder if
your choices matter in this game like if
we're gonna see a different ending yeah
well I killed a whole train and oh I
came out of the train crash says Jonah
Anne did I come out of the train crash
just like shootings just like pop pop
pop pop all right here we go alright
let's go through this door an hour back
outside great I want to know what by the
way what and I stopped to see what
glowing eyes are there's no eyes that
glow in the dark so I find this more fun
exactly look at the map alien aliens
would be dope if this is aliens this
game is amazing I'm not gonna go back
and look at the map that's right Drake -
no my nose is right that's cuz I have
allergies when I was a kid so I just
destroyed my nose it's pretty great I'm
a hideous monster and that's signal so
ladies wearing a shirt this is blood on
so but also ominous the story about our
weekend yet yeah dad this is exactly
what I did last week again dance eyes
bigger
Andy butts the only survivor of the
plane crash I'm breakable I'm an alien
says a Josh weird
yep yep yep Lord Vaughn dirt killing the
game alright let's go back out let's see
what's going on here
[Music]
actually that creepy noise though yeah
yeah it's kind of good the noises are
fun and creepy alright here we go let's
go in this way wait did we just come
from this way there we go
oh here we go where the forest what's in
the entrance the force that was mention
on that map I'd seen oh ok the sign
point out various campsites
that you could burn people out walking
pots in the wood I mentioned a river and
maybe a washroom but the rest was too
faded to see clearly I almost wish I had
paid more attention to those crazy
scribblings maybe I would have been less
nervous about any of the dark forest
yeah but we have a gun and a knife and
we are a killer oh oh now we're in it
dude look at this we're in the forest
this is great you know I gotta say I
thought the whole game was gonna be just
us in the in the house if I could find
my way around sure well I like that
animation alright let's see oh man we're
gonna a fire pit done 10th few members
well you know what I see some
irresponsible campers didn't put up
their campfire let's kill them this is
me this is where I've been staying Oh
interesting
me and Rachel perhaps our honeymoon are
sexy honeymoon I don't know why they
abandon their campsite maybe oh wait to
folding camp sure oh but why because a
killers on the loose
a killer named Aaron [ __ ] Blair
hmm oh yeah my shirt says blood
everybody blood and huge letters I got
it on screen calm and you can too all
right here we go
I'm already lost okay wait well we're
back we're back of the campsite okay
here we go
let's go back this way this is a this is
gonna be the valve thing all over I'm
telling you right now this is gonna be a
mess oh god wait a second sure every is
the new trick
Oh oh wait a second ah bugs ah no no no
no don't look don't does that say don't
look back
don't go on or just say don't go on no
no oh we will don't tell me how to live
first rule of getting me to do something
tell me not to do it the grimy sink we
get it it's all grimy and dirty yep yeah
I looked almost clean oh I wasn't much
in the way of clean water there for the
sink did work all right well it's can we
drink I mean one must be thirsty at this
point don't really seem useful did I
bother to take it I've been taking the
wooden plank yes yeah we take everything
cuz we're gonna need it Oh everything is
discussing in this town yeah well we
took the plank maybe we can burn it in
the fire but the real question is uh uh
Lucretia is 69 the real question is are
there valves outside and can we turn
them I've been asking myself that for
the past 10 minutes gotta get that
valves give me them valves give me them
valves give me them valves hashtag valve
life what a valve life what happened oh
oh I got him got that bug look at I
killed him
gotcha bug that's right one more dead
thing in this game where I'm a killer
there we go another Matt soon as first
one oh good we got out of the woods talk
about horror alright I've got an exam
tomorrow thanks German I'll sue good
seeing you eat the dead bug eater you
murderers Thank You secrets
eat it I killed it sorry guys I had to
do it a lot of people want to see me eat
a bug it's on the ground somewhere you
guys should have been faster on the
drive what a problem alright just wanted
to get out of there so I'm not going
back to the campsite right let's keep
going
oh so do we want to go back to the
campsite and check if we can burn the
plank oh I don't know are we alright
semi-shade we should yeah alright we're
gonna do it cuz I feel like we missed
out before we kind of missed out on some
stuff it was like you sure you really
want to do this stuff and I was like I
don't know whatever and then they were
like are you worried you're sure though
right now it's like sure I don't care
they're like guess what can't go back
it's like how do I get back this way all
these shrubs look the same I'll not be a
good tracker here we go I don't know
let's burn the thing can I burn the
thing please can I burn the thing please
oh here we go
Dona to keep look but I thought if I
keep rooting the camps ensue and walk-in
at me that's we want to see someone else
so far we've seen is your other people
wouldn't it be funny if at one point I
found out like one of these buttons
actually did something different I
didn't kill the bug it's here Wow what's
that there's more than one bug this
place is putrid I know what a disgusting
place open uh-uh as your a place to put
my plank you know what I'm talking about
wait there was some rumbling here wait
for a second the thing rumbled why did
it do that whoa hey what's this what
whoa yeah you read the notebook alright
doesn't have to be cheap but not
everybody can afford whoa oh Rachel's
the last one on there and look if you
read down the sign it says Hawai did you
sure which I think we all know what that
Rachel name is last the list and a mark
beside blue ink name is Daffy and live
even crossed out the same blue ink dead
that day else went crossed out these
marks look older and more
I'm a killer put the plank in the hole
you know I'm saying you know put the
plank in the hole
guys don't you guys ever tie him up I
need to go to me Rachel's dead bro we
all know it she's in the sewer she's
dead Rachel's dead I'm sorry
you're losing your mind Rachel's dad we
all know it it's all women I'm a serial
murderer yeah we know this I think we've
all just come to terms and by the way
fine with it not your even yawning yeah
so bored with being sober yeah I'm just
randomly going